this comes after metro police reporting
a substantial rise since this time last
year
and these thieves are going after
certain particular models madison
kimbrough on this story live to tell us
what you need to do to protect your car
listen up
yeah so metro reports that there's been
a 21 increase
in stolen cars and trucks since last
year that's in the southeast part of the
valley and also right here
in spring valley you can take a look
we're at a parking lot right now where
there are many trucks
and i spoke to those that have
experienced this firsthand to agree that
trucks
are a hot commodity they broke into the
truck and
steering columns demolished destroyed
truck owners beware according to metro
police thieves are targeting truck
models like the ford f series
chevrolet silverados and dodge ram
they're also going after certain model
cars like honda civics and honda accords
so what makes these trucks so desirable
general manager terry hoisington at
fairway chevrolet
explains where we have a particularly
strong
used truck market but the values have
continued to increase over the last
three or four months
so now they're really at record high
prices which makes them
targets for people to steal them because
they're very very easy to sell
according to metro the majority of these
burglaries happen at night
on mondays and tuesdays they take a
screwdriver
they stick it right here patrick
cornigay had his 1999 ford 250 broken
into a couple months ago
i'd heard from my next door neighbor
that there had been a guy walking around
taking pictures of my gate after i
moved it forward so
it's an organization is what i think i
mean they're working together here
they know what they're doing corny says
metro recommended a jimmy jammer a
device to put inside of your door panel
along with adding additional security
around the property they recommended
cameras which i have
in big solar lights which i have now so
i've taken some precautions since then
[Music]
now other deterrents horn alarms
flashing lights
and steering wheel locks and as
simple as it may seem you guys need to
lock your vehicles even if it's parked
at your home driveway or somewhere where
you feel is very safe
lock your car doors that is the safest
and most securest way to get these
thieves away from your vehicle
but like we said in the package in the
story we have a lot of tips for you to
really just make sure that you can keep
your vehicle safe
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now